مساء الخير واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه
التغطيه المتواصله او الحيه والمباشره
للصراع المسلح في السودان صراع عسكري بين
البرهان وحميتي ولا افق لنهايته حتى الان
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش السوداني استقرار الموقف
العملياتي الجيش اشار ايضا في بيانه الى
توسيع نطاق تامين منطقه الخرطوم لتجنب
الحاق اضرار بالمناطق السكنيه فيما جدد
دعوته لعناصر الدعم السريع بالاستسلام
بيان الجيش اتهم قوات الدعم السريع
باستخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه واكد على
ان الاتصالات ما زالت مستمره مع الدول
الاجنبيه الراغبه في اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
في المقابل كشف فارس النور مستشار قائد
الدعم السريع للعربيه كشف عن هدنه جديده
خلال الساعات القادمه كما اكد ان قوات
الدعم السريع ستحقق اهدافها سواء بالعمل
العسكري او بالتفاوض مستشار حميد تاكد
للعربيه ان قوات الدعم السريع لم تطرح
نفسها بديلا للجيش بل تريد اصلاحه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاثناء قال مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قال بان الكتله الاوروبيه لن تسمح بانفجار
الوضع في السودان واضاف على هامش اجتماع
لوزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اضاف ان
عمليه اجلاء موظفي الاتحاد قد نجحت
لقد كانت عمليه معقده لكنها ناجحه موظف
الاتحاد الاوروبي 21 شخصا موجودون بالفعل
في اوروبا والعديد من مواطني الاتحاد
الاوروبي خارج السودان بالفعل لا استطيع
ان اعطيك الرقم الملموسه لكن تقريبا اكثر
من الف شخص اود ان اشكر فرنسا على
مساهمتها علينا ان نواصل الضغط من اجل
تسويه سياسيه لا يمكننا ان نتحمل ان ينهار
السودان لانه سيرسل موجات صدمه في جميع
انحاء افريقيا
بوريل قال ردا على سؤال العربيه ان
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على المكونين
العسكريين في السودان ويقوم ببذل جهود
مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب للوصول الى تسويه
سياسيه
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على الطرفين ويقوم
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه لقد كنت اتحدث مع جميع
الجيران وجميع الاصدقاء حتى مع وجود
الجنرلين اللذين يقودان القوات رساله
المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب واسكات
المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث عن الحل
السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذه الحرب
وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج مواطنينا
لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك تراه انت
تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج مواطنونا
ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو
اخراجهم
واضافت الوزاره انها تمكنت من ذلك بفضل
التعاون مع شركائها وخاصه فرنسا من دون
ذكر عدد الاشخاص الذين تم اجلائهم
في ولايه البحر الاحمر شرق السودان مراسل
العربيه نزار البقدونس ينضم الينا اهلا بك
نزار انقل الصوره لنا من حيث انت
السعوديه
حقيقه راعينا يعني راعينا انه الناس جايه
من ظروف نفسيه معينه حاولنا نسهل كل
الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من الاجراءات
حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني مشت به طريقه
سلسه جدا
سهلنا كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات كيف يتم التنسيق من التحرك من
العاصمه الخرطوم الى هذه المدينه في شرق
السودان هل من عقبات امنيه واجهت البعثات
والرعايه حقيقه يعني بعد تحركهم من خارج
الخرطوم لا توجد اي مشاكل حدثت بعد
المشاكل حقتهم داخل الخرطوم قبل تحرك بعض
البعثات لان الخرطوم يعني شويه على
الكنترول كان صعب شويه لكن بعد خروج طوال
احنا بنتم متابعتهم عبر الفرق المختلفه في
شارع حقيقه العمل ده تم بترتيب قياده
منطقه البحر الاحمر العسكريه ونحن حقيقه
تقريبا يعني شكرا جزيلا المنطقه لمتابعه
الدقيقه
لهذا الامر
حتى وصولهم هنا بتكون الاجراءات كل
الاجراءات اكتملت للدخول والرباط السفن
واكتمال الاجراءات الخاصه بالجوازات
والهجره ما حجم القطعه البحريه التي يبدو
انها في طريقها الان لبورسودان وعدد من
تبقه في طريقهم من السودان الى خارج
السودان
الان الان نحن بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن
حجم التنسيق ايضا بين الجيش بين الامن
البحري بين الشرطه هذه الامور تحتاج الى
تنسيق وعدد الرعايه الان في ازدياد في
بورسودان كيف تواجهون كل هذه التحديات
والانظار كلها متجهه صوب المطار وصوب
الميناء لا الامر المسيطر عليه تماما
الحمد لله رب العالمين هنالك ليان وخلايا
تعمل على مدارس ساعه 24 ساعه ليل نهار
لتسهيل هذه المهام وفي تنسيق تام جدا يعني
لا توجد اي
سلبيات يعني الان حتى الان كل العمليات
تتم بدقه شديده جدا وحتى الناس الجو تم
اجلاون يعني حتى ما حسوا بانه في اجراءات
ولا حسوا بانه في تقدس او طوابير يعني كل
كل المهم المهمه طلعت بصوره سلسه وطيبه هل
وصلتكم اي رسائل او برقيات للخروج من
السودان سواء كان عرفنا بان التايلاند
الان في الطريق الى ان تبعث وترتب لي تخرج
رعاياها هل من دول اخرى الان تنسق معكم
حتى تجلي رعاياها من السودان عبر بورسودان
اقصد هنا نعم بالتاكيد يعني كله كله كله
على مدارس صعب نستلم طلبات
لدخول سفن يعني انا قبل وصولكم هنا بنصف
ساعه وصلتنا طلب لسفينه هنديه اخرى وايضا
يتم للسفينه كوريه
وما زالت طلبات مستمره يعني اكبر الجاليات
التي وصلت الجاليه الهنديه كيف تواجهون
اخراج
نحو 1000 هندي من السودان
والله تم الترتيب لذلك ما في اي مشكله
الامور كلها طيبه وصل اليوم الصباح والان
هم مؤسفين موجوده داخل الميناء وهم في
النقاط بتاع التجمع ومنتظرين اكتمال هذه
الاعداد يعني لا تريد اي مشاكل لا توجد اي
شكاوي ونحن يعني الاجتهاد كبير جدا
بحيث انه تتمه العمليات تابع صوره طيبه
كيف السؤال الاخير كيف يتم توفيقه اوضاع
من فقد الاوراق الثبوتيه الاشتباكات التي
حدثت في الخرطوم جعلت كثير ممن وصلوا الى
شرق السودان من غير اوراق ثبوتيه هل
باستطاعه الغرف المعنيه بالجوازات ان تسهل
وتمهد الخروج الان من السلس من دون اي
عقبات او تعقيدات بالتاكيد لا توجد اي
مشاكل بالنسبه ما يلينا نحن من اجراءات في
السودان يعني القوات المسلحه يعني ادى
التعليمات واضحه جدا انه تسهيل كافه
الاجراءات الخاصه بين في بعض الاجراءات
طبعا ما خاصه بين خاصه بالسفارات للدول
المستضيفه دي طبعا احنا يعني
لا يمكن اتدخل فيها الدوله الحصص عند
اجراءات ايضا اما ما يلينا من الاجراءات
نحن يعني شغالين شغل استثنائي تماما
هل تتوقعون وصول اي طائرات خلال الساعه
المقبله الساعتين المقبلتين
نعم هنالك عدد عدد من الطلبات الطائرات
نحن نتوقع خلال من الاخر الى اصول طائرتين
اللواء الركن صلاح بابكر عمر ابو حسبه
قائد الفرقه 101 مشاه البحريه رئيس اللجنه
العليا لاجلاء البعثات والرعايه
الدبلوماسيه شكرا لك على هذا اللقاء
المباشر من داخل مدينه بورسودان تعود الان
الى الزملاء في الاستوديو
دع المراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي وشكر جزيل
لضيفك الكريم
الوصول بمواطنيهم الى بر الامان كان هدف
الدول التي يوجد لها رعايه في السودان
لاخراجهم عبر عمليات اجلاء عاجله عده
مسارات تمت لعمليات الاجلاء منها عبر
قاعده ولد سيدنا الجوي في ام درمان ونقلهم
الى بورتسودان ومنها جوا الى دولهم خط اخر
للاجلاء كان ايضا عبر بورسودان لكن بحرا
عبر سفن حربيه تنقلهم الى مدينه جده على
الضفه الاخرى من البحر الاحمر قبل نقل
المواطنين الى بلدانهم من مسارات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب من السودان كان توقف
طائرات الاجلاء في الاردن كمحطه وقوف
مؤقته قبل الطيران الى السودان ونقل من
يرغب في مغادره البلاد واخر المسارات هو
عبر جيبوت المجاوره التي توقفت فيها
طائرات عسكريه من عده دول بغرض نقل
الرعايه من السودان ومن هذه المعسكرات
قاعده ليموني الاميركيه التي تم عب رها
نقل بعثه واشنطن في الخرطوم اضافه لعشرات
المواطنين من دول اخرى
حيث ينضم الينا مدير مرصد الشفافيه
والسياسات سليمان علي بلده اهلا بك سيد
سليمان معنا في هذه التغطيه المباشره
والمستمره للاحداث في السودان بدايه وفي
ظل يعني التضارب المستمر في التصريحات هذا
الجانب يؤكد شيئا ما والجانب الاخر يخرج
ليمفي ما قاله الطرف الاخر هل يمكن القول
ان الحقيقه هي اولى ضحايا الحرب
بالتاكيد ان هذا سلوك يعني تمارسه كل
الاطراف المتقاتله في العالم الحرب
النفسيه الحرب العالميه
استقلال الاعلام لاعطاء انطباعات معينه عن
الاداء الاطراف العسكريه المتحاربه الى
اخره فليس هناك شيء جديد في ذلك لكن
المواطن على الارض يرى عينيه ماذا يدور
ويعرف تماما من هي الجهه المسيطره على
المنطقه السكنيه التي يعيشون فيها او تلك
التي تسعى الى طرد تلك الجهه من مواقعها
الى اخره فالحقيقه يعرفها المواطن بحساب
ما يتعرض له من مخاطر نتيجه لهذا الاقتتال
المستمر في الاحياء السكنيه وما التي
تريدك سيد سليمان من الخرطوم هي نفس
الحقائق التي تريدكم من مشاهدات المواطنين
في الاحياء من التغطيه الاعلاميه المستمره
لقناه العربيه والحدث وكل القنوات
النشطه في التغطيه المباشره لهذه الاحداث
نسبه
لاهميتها وما تعنيه لامن وسلامه المواطن
السوداني والامن وسلامه المنطقه وكل
الغاره الافريقيه هذه الاحداث تنمو عن
مخاطر الجسيمه في بدايه يعاني منها
المواطن يعاني منها المقيمين الاجانب
والشيعاني منها ان لم يكن تم ذلك بالفعل
الامن الاقليمي والعالمي كما يحدث الان
يعني استمعنا الى لقاء الزميل نزار في
بورت سودان من غرفه العمليات لاجلاء
المواطنين الاجانب يعني في ظل استمرار
مطالبات الاجلاء وفي ظل استمرار خروج
المواطنين وبعض الس فارات تغلق سفراتها
بشكل نهائي والى اجل يعني غير مسمم كيف
نفهم مطالبات
مستشار حميتي بالهدنه او هدنه قادمه بعد
ساعات قليله هل هي في ظل استمرار الاجلاء
ربما
الاجلاء طبعا معنيه به او معنيون به
المواطنون الجاليات الاجنبيه والمنظمين من
مواطني العالم في السودان ولقد وصل
السفاراتهم ومنظماتهم العامله بالخرطوم
الى نتيجه وصل اليها المواطن السوداني
بالفعل انه ليس من امان من لاي شخص في
منزله الخرطوم حتى بدايه هذه الصدامات
كانت تعتبر مدينه امنه مدينه كما يسميها
الاجانب
يعني كموقع اسري اي بان بامكانهم ان ياتوا
مع اسرهم واطفالهم
لم يكن يتوقعوا ان يحدثوا ما حدث وكذلك
المواطن السودانيين مع ارتفاع حده التوتر
والحرب الاعلاميه بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه والدعم السريع في الايام التي
سبقت الانفجار لكن في تقديري ان المواطن
وان المقيمين الاجانب لم يكن ان يتوقعوا
هذه الاحداث بهذه السرعه وفي هذه الدرجه
من العنف المكثف الذي لا يراعي حرمه
لحمايه المدنيين او
لكل ما يهم المدنيين من مواقع اساسيه
لامنهم وسلامتهم ورعايه صحتهم كالمستشفيات
مواقع المياه مواقع توليد الكهربائي الى
اخره الطرفين اثبتا عدم التزامهما بابسط
قواعد القانون الدولي الانساني في اداره
الحروب الداخليه والدوليه طيب سيد سليمان
يعني حملتي قبل قليل قال سنحقق مكاسب سواء
عسكريه او بالتفاوض هل هنا ربما يلمح
بانهم على استعداد لجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات
ذكر قبل ايام في مقابله مع احدى القنوات
انه ان هذه الحرب من ينتصر فيها خاسر كذلك
الفريق اول البرهان في مقابله بالامس ذكر
ان هذه حرب عبثيه الرجلان يستقيان في
تقييم حقيقي لما يدور الان ولكنهما لا
يبديان اي استعداد على ارض الواقع
يعني
التصرف بما يثبت هذا الفهم ايغاف الاقتتال
حتى يسمح للمواطنين
بتامين انفسهم واحتياجاتهم الاساسيه
للحياه ايصال المرضى والجرحى الى
المستشفيات دفن جسس الموتى المتناثره على
شوارع الخرطوم فالطرفين في نظري مدانين
بتجاهل هذه القواعد الاساسيه لقوانين
الحرب العالميه وهما في نظر الشعب
السوداني يتحملان مسؤوليه مشتركه فيما
يدور من ماسي ومن تحطيم لامن وسلامه
المواطن
وما يدور من عنف اشواقي ينال كل الاطراف
الطرفان مدنان كما تقول سيد سليمان ولكن
برايك وحسب المعطيات على ارض المعركه الى
من ترجح الكفه
اذا نظرت الى البيانات العسكريه الصادره
من القوات المسلحه السودانيه تجدي ان فيها
درجه من الواقعيه عندما تقول ان قوات
الدعم السريعه انتشرت في الاحياء انه يجري
تطهير هذه الاحياء بصوره تدريجيه اي ان
الطرفين بالتالي يقولان انها امد هذا
الاقتصاد سيستمر لفتره سيستمر في داخل
الاحياء السكنيه وهذا شيء خطير للغايه اذ
ان ذلك سيعني مزيد من المعاناه ومزيد من
التقطير للمواطنين للابياء الابرياء في
منازلهم ومزيد من تدمير البنى التحتيه
بدايه بالمستشفيات ومحطات المياه ومواقع
التوليد الكهربائي وكل البنى التحتيه التي
كانت هشه في الاساس في السودان فلكنهما مع
العلم بكل هذا يقترحان في بياناتهم
العسكريه ان الحرب سيطول امدها في الخرطوم
وفي
السودان المختصله المختلفه بصوره خاصه في
دافور وفي كردفان ونرى ان ذلك هذا
الاقتتال لقد حدث بالفعل في الولايه
الشماليه الى اخره طيب يعني الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تطول هذه الحرب سيد سليمان يعني
يقال بان الدعم السريع اسلحتهم محدوده
وكميه الاسلحه لديهم ايضا محدوده فالن
تنفذ الاسلحه لديهم الا ان كانوا يدعمون
ربما بالاسلحه من جهه ما
في واقع الامر يبدو انهاك قوات الدعم
السريع واستنزاف
مواردها من تموين في الغذاء وفي الذخيره
وفي يعني ايجاد العلاج
المعالجه الطبيه لجرحاهم الى اخره هو جزء
من الاستراتيجيه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
في السعي للانتصار على هذه القوات ولكن
يرى المواطن السوداني في مواقع في المواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مثلا استيلاء قوات
الدعم السريع على مواقع تخزين للذخيره
بكميات كبيره جدا جدا استولوا عليها من
مخازن القوات المسلحه السودانيه في مواقع
مختلفه بما معناه ان هذه الزخائر ستسحب في
الى اسلحه قوات الدعم السريع
وسطيل من امد هذه الحرب العبسيه كما وصفها
الفريق الاول برهان بالتالي ليس هناك من
سبيل لحسم عسكري على الارض لهذا الاقتتال
وندعو كلا من الفريق الاول البركان
والفريق الاول حمدتي الى الاستماع الى كل
هذه المناشدات من مواطنيهم ومن كل القوى
الاقليميه والدوليه لايقاف هذه الحرب فورا
يعني القبول بهدنه لغرض انساني بما يسمح
دراسه المواطن السوداني وبما يسمح باعطاء
فرصه للسلام حتى يعود السودان الى
استغرائي ما نتمنى طبعا للسودان كل السلام
باذن الله يعني لابد ان اشير قبل ان انهي
حديثي معك سيد سليمان الى هذا العاجل
امامنا على الشاشه بان وزير خارجيه
الامارات يثمن دور السعوديه في اجلاء
الرعايه الاماراتيين والاجانب من السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك من نيويورك مدير مرصد
الشفافيه والسياسات سليمان علي بلده
[موسيقى]
ربنا يستر
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو حصريه لقناه العربيه
حجم الدمار والاضرار التي خلفها القصف على
منطقه الكلاكله او الكلاكله القبه الواقعه
جنوب الخرطوم نتابع
المنطق
فوق الراس
الى برلين حيث تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام اهلا بك راغده اذا عمليات
الاجلاء ووصول المواطنين الالمان من
السودان الى برلين متواصله انقلي لنا
الصوره لديك
اهلا بك فاطمه نحن الان في مطار برلين
الذي يعني مفترض وصلت اليه طائره صباحا
ماتي من الاردن من قاعده الزرقاء التي
يعني تنقل اليها او ينقل اليها الجيش
الالماني الطائرات في العمليه التي يجريها
لاجلاء الرعايه الالمان وغير الالمان ايضا
حتى الان طائره واحده وصلت من الذين تم
اجلائهم الى الاردن الى برلين ما زلنا
ننتظر وصول طائره ثانيه لانه نعلم بان
هناك اكثر من 300 شخص تم اجلائهم من
الخرطوم اكثر من النصف تقريبا يعني قرابه
المئه
هم مواطنون المان المتبقون يحملون جنسيات
مختلفه 43 منهم يحملون الجنسيه الهولنديه
خمسه عشر يحملون الجنسيه النمساويه اضافه
الى رعايه دول كثيره اخرى ليس فقط داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن من خارجها ايضا مثل
بريطانيا واستراليا نقلهم الجيش الالماني
على طائرات
خاصه من الخرطوم الى الاردن قبل قليل ايضا
كنت اتحدث الى متحدث باسم قياده العمليات
عمليات الجيش الالماني لاسال ما اذا كانت
يعني القصف الذي نتحدث عنه على مطار
الخرطوم يؤثر على عمليات الاجلاء هذا وقال
بانه هذه العمليات الاجلاء لا تحدث من
مطار الخرطوم الدولي هي تحدث من مطار في
خرطوم في العاصمه خرطوم ولكن لا يمكن ان
نحدد مكان هذا المطار بطبيعه الحال لاسباب
امنيه لذلك عمليات القصف الجاريه الان لم
تؤثر على عمليه
اجلاء الرعايه الالمان المتبقين هناك
ويعني رعايه دول اخرى في هذه العمليه التي
يجريها الجيش الالماني المتحدث اكد لي
ايضا بانه اليوم سيتم عمليه سيتم يعني نقل
رعايه اخرون من الخرطوم الى الاردن لم
يحدد رقم يعني قال بانه هذه الاعداد ما
زالت غير واضحه ولكن اليوم هم ايضا يعني
لي ان يستكملوا عمليه الاجلاء هذه على اي
حال سيكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي مساء بعد قرابه
الثلاث ساعات من الان لوزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه ووزير الدفاع الالماني على
الارجح سيعلنان فيه انتهاء عمليات الاجلاء
هذه ربما ينتظرون يعني قرار او ينتظرون
تاكيد من الجيش الالماني المتواجد في
الخرطوم ليقول او ليبلغهم بانه هذه
العمليات انتهت وتم نقل كل من يعني سجل مع
السفاره الالمانيه وابدا رغبته بمغادره
الاراضي السودانيه يعني اريد ان الالفت
ايضا بانه التوجيهات من او يعني ما تقول
الخارجيه الالمانيه هنا بانه هي تنصح
بالاجلاء وهي من واجبها ان تساعد الرعايه
الالمان الذين يريدون مغادره السودان على
المغادره ولكن يعني المغادره ليست اجباريه
ربما هناك من اختار ان يبقى في السودان
على الارجح من حمله الجنسيات المزدوجه
والنصيحه التي يعني تقدمها بالبقاء في
اماكن امنه بعيده عن اماكن
الاشتباكات الجاريه شكرا لك من برلين
مراسله العربيه راغده بهنام على كل هذه
المعلومات
اسبوع ثاني من المواجهات المسلحه في
السودان لا صوت يعلو على صوت الرصاص ولا
مؤشر ينذر بحل قريب المواجهه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بدات باطلاق نار كثيف حول
مباني المدينه الرياضيه في منطقه سوبا
جنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم القتال بعد ذلك
انتقل سريعا الى حي المطار المتاخم لمقر
القياده العامه للجيش حيث يوجد بيت
الضيافه الذي يقيم فيه طرفان الحرب
البرهان وكبار القاده العسكريين وسط
الخرطوم وبينما تداولت وسائل الاعلام عن
الدعم السريع سيطرته على مطار مروي
والقاعده الجويه اضافه الى الاعلان عن
احتجاز عدد من الضباط كانوا في القاعده تم
تداول معلومات عن استيلاء قوات الدعم
السريع على القصر الجمهوري في قلب الخرطوم
اضافه الى اجزاء واسعه من مقر القياده
العامه للجيش نيران الحريق بعدها الى خارج
الخرطوم لتصل عددا من المدن مثل نيالا
والفاشر والجنيه في ولايات دارفور ومدينه
الابيض في ولايه شمال كردفان القتال تركز
ايضا حول مقرات الدعم السريع في شارع عبيد
ختم وفي مدينه بحري وام درمان ليس معروفا
على وجه الدقه من يسيطر على ماذا فكل طرف
يزعم بسط سيطرته على موقع استراتيجي قبل
ان يبادر الاخر سريعا باعلان الشيء نفسه
ومع استمرار المواجهات يدفع المدنيون
الثمن كعاده اي صراع خاصه وان كان مسلحا
نقابه اطباء السودان افادت بان مناطق عده
في العاصمه الخرطوم تعرضت لقصف بالاسلحه
الثقيله واعلنت النقابه عن مقتل عدد من
المدنيين في منطقه الكلاكله مضيفه ان
المستشفيات باتت مكتظه بالاصابات الخطيره
وناشدت نقابه اطباء السودان ناشدت الكوادر
الطبيه لتقديم المساعده ويد العون للكوادر
العامله بالمستشفيات
قبل ذلك اعلنت نقابه الاطباء ارتفاع عدد
الوفيات وذلك منذ بدايه الاشتباكات الى
273 من المدنيين النقابه سجلت نحو 1580
حاله اصابه منذ بدايه الاشتباكات مؤكده ان
العدد مرشح للزياده مع صعوبه في الحصر
الدقيق بسبب طبعا صعوبه التنقل بين
المستشفيات اشارت النقابه كذلك الى ان
69% من المستشفيات باتت بالفعل متوقفه عن
الخدمه
وفي هذه الاثناء ومع استمرار الاشتباكات
تستمر خدمه الانترنت في الانقطاع بالسودان
بشكل شبهي كامل وذلك وفق ما افاد موقع نت
بلوكس لمراقبه الانترنت واظهرت بيانات
الموقع انهيارا شبه كامل للاتصال
بالانترنت لتصل نسبه الاتصال الى اثنين في
المئه مقارنه بالمستوى الطبيعي
معي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني محمود لعوته اهلا بك سيد محمود
معنا في استديوهات العربيه وفي هذه
التغطيه المباشره والمستمره لما يحدث في
السودان بدايه لنبدا بالهدنه التي ذكرها
مستشار حميتيل العربيه بانك هدنه خلال
ساعات القادمه كيف تفهم هذه الخطوه من
جانب حميتي والحديث عن موضوع الهدنه او
قضيه الهدنه يعني لازم ينبني على التجارب
السابقه للهدنات التي حددها الطرفان
وطالبهما بعض الجهات الدوليه بتوقف القتال
حتى تكون هنالك مسارات امنه للمواطنين اما
للتنقل او الذهاب الى المستشفيات او لقضاء
حاجاتهم في الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
ولكن اعتقد هذه الدعوه الى الهدنه
انا اعتقد قد لا تكون ناجحه مئه بالمئه
اذا لم اذا لم يلتزم الطرفان
بوقفه اطلاق النار نهائيا ولكن يعني في ظل
حتى عدم الالتزام بالهدنه سيد محمود ما
زال هناك دعوات للهدنه لماذا تستمر هذه
الدعوات في ظل الخروقات
انا اعتقد هذه يمكن قد تكون مناورات
عسكريه اذا كان من الطرفين انا لا اتهم اي
طرف ولكن الهدنه نفسها من الطرفين لها
مغازي اخرى يعني قد تكون مخفيه ولا يريد
اي طرف منهم ان يعلن عن انه ماذا يريد ان
التمركز نعم نعم
للشخص الذي يعني يعني تعرض لهزات كثيره في
هذه المواجهات حتى الان لكن انا ممكن
التقطت في العربيه خبر في اخر الليل بانه
في هدنه دعى اليها حاكم شمال دارفور في
الفاشر
واعتقد كانت ناجحه اللي هي اشتركت فيها
الحركات المسلحه والشرطه اللي هو كان وزعه
بوف نقطه معينه انه الشرطه تكون مسؤوله عن
مراقبه
الاسواق
وبعض الحركات المسلحه تقوم مسؤوله عن
المنشات الحكوميه لكن ما ليس لدي معلومات
عن مدى هذه الهدنه هل مستمر حتى الان في
مدينه الفاشر ولا اعتقد في الفاشر في
الفاشر نعم دعى لها حاكم شمال دارفور
واعتقد وجدت تجاوب من الطرفين وجدت جواب
من الطرفين
بالتزام بالهودنا اذا طبقت هل قوات الدعم
السريع اكثر عددا من قوات الجيش ام العكس
والله انا حسب علمي طبعا القوات المسلحه
السودانيه عندها حاميه كبيره في الفاشل
هناك وممكن متعدده حتى الاخصام يعني في
سلاح طبي في كل الاقسام موجوده لكن حسب
علمي طبعا
منطقه الفاشر هي كانت منطقه عمليات لقوات
الدعم السريع في في الفتره اللي كان فيها
نظام البشير لمطارده
الحركات المسلحه انا اعتقد قد تكون الكف
متوازيه ولكن اريح قفه الجيش باعتباره هو
جيش نظامي يعني المفروض تكون عنده قوات
كافيه في تلك المنطقه لانه مهمه جدا اول
حاجه متعقمه للحدود ومنطقه مهمه في غرب
السودان هي الفاشل الكبرى المدن في
السودان وبالتالي انا اعتقد يوجد يعني
يعني كميات كبيره
المنطقه طيب سيد محمود يعني بالحديث عن
الحركات المسلحه اين هم يعني انا اسال هنا
عن حركه مالك عقار حركه ياسر عرمان حركه
مني اركم الناوي يعني لا صوت لهم يعني لا
ينضمون لتلك الجهه او لتلك بالتالي اين هم
في ظل هذا الصراع والاشتباكات القائمه
السوداني هم اكتفوا بالبيانات العاديه انه
نادوا بوقف الطرفان الى
اطلاق النار وانا اعتقد كل الحركات
المسلحه كل الاطياف السودانيه السياسيه
الموجوده في الساحه الان لا تستطيع ان
تاخذ موقفي ايجابي ولا تستطيع ان يعني
ترجح كفه
الجيش او الدعم السريع لانها لانها تخشى
من عواقب مستقبليه يعني لان لو حتى الان
هنالك غموض لا تعرف من الذي حيكون منتصلا
فلذلك يعني اتخذت يعني مواقف يعني مايعه
وليست سليمه ولا يعني يعني تجري في نفق
الحلول السريعه يعني فبالتالي يعني
المناداه بحلول من داخل السودان اعتقد قد
لا تفيد كثيرا من اين يمكن ان ياتي الحل
براي انا اعتقد الان الحل الدولي هو موجود
او من الدول المجاوره الاقليميه اللي
بهمها
الشان السودان وبالذات العمق الامني
الاستراتيجي لها يعني الدول انا اعتقد
الدول نتحدث عن اي دوله تحديدا انا مصر
القريبه هي لانه عند عمق استراتيجي بحكومه
علاقه التاريخيه بالسودان من مئات السنين
وتعاملها مع حكومات مختلفه في السودان انا
اعتقد هم الاقرب لوضع مبادره سريعه للتدخل
يعني الم تقول
انا اعتقد انه لو لو كسفت الجهود
واستعانت مصر ببعض الدول الاقليميه في
المنطقه بالذات الدول العربيه وبعض الدول
الافريقيه انا اعتقد ان قد نصل الى مبادره
توقف في البدايه يعني
الاقتتال بين الطرفين هذا اهم حاجه يعني
في هذه المرحله لابد ان تقف صوت البندقيه
والا يعني السودان لن يشهد اي سلام ولاني
يشهد اي استقرار وانا اعتقد كما ذكرت انت
انه الشعب السوداني هو حيكون هو الخاسر
الاول والاخير يعني احنا الان بنشوف
يعني قصص محزنه في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي المناشده بانه لدي مريض يحتاج
لدواء لدي يعني
ابي كبير سنيا يريد ان ينتقل في داخل
الخرطوم او يخرج من الخرطوم يجد هنالك
مجاد هنالك لا توجد مياه فهنالك قصص محزنه
انا اعتقد الان الالام التي نتجت عن الحرب
هي افضع من الحرب
الوضع الوضع الان افزع من الحرب التي
الافظع من الذين الان يتقاتلون في الشوارع
ووضع يعني مزري
ولا يعني صوره قادمه ونحن نتكلم عن عشره
او تسعه ايام طب برايك سيد محمود يعني في
ظل هذه الازمه الانسانيه التي تتحدث عنها
هل يمكن فتح ممرات امنه لايصال مساعدات
امميه مساعدات دوليه للمتضررين من هذه
الحرب في الضمانات كل المنظمات الدوليه
انا اخر الاجلاء يعني هناك كان ضمانات
لاجلاء
الاجانب الدول كل الدول تدخل بقوات عسكريه
يعني الاجلاء هذا تم بطائرات عسكريه
بملاحظه مرافقه بعض الجنود وانا اعتقد انه
الطرفان يعطوا اعتبارات
مهمه لكل الدول باجلاء رعاياها خوف من من
السمعه السيئه لهما يعني كان حريصين بانه
يعني يتعاملوا معامله
دبلوماسيه دقيقه حتى يعني لا يؤخذ عليهم
موقف سلبي باتجاه تصرفاته
بانه تعاون مع الجانب الامريكي
لاجل هل كان هذا تصرف سلبي من جانبه وحاول
احراج ربما الحكومه الامريكيه كما يرى
البعض ما هو لا تصرف سلبي يعني انا بعتبره
الجانبين
نحن العربيه بتنقل كل يوم انه الجانبين
انه نحن نتعامل مع القوات الامريكيه او
السفاره كذا
خرجت ونفت مساعده الدعم السريع لاجلاء
الموضوع
المساله هذه امتداد للتصريحات المتبادله
بينهم من اجل شنو كل واحد يعني يعني يحفظ
موقفه
الايجابي في مثل هذه المواقف يعني يعني
يمكن احنا في البدايه الان الان الصحفيين
يعانون كثيرا جدا من الحصول على المعلومات
الدقيقه يعني يمكن نادر ما نلقى انه يكون
في صحفي ميداني محم من الطرفين للتغطيه
الحيه المباشره
التليفونيه بين القنوات وكل شخص وكل طرف ي
كل ما يقوله ولكن النقل الحقيقي للميداني
للعمل الصحفي المهني الطبيعي غير موجود
الان
بنسبه كبيره بنسبه كبيره الا مشاهد يعني
مشاهد قليله ومشاهد انسانيه لكن المعلومات
الحقيقه والدقيقه لم يستطيع الاعلاميين
الموجودين لمكاتب
القنوات الفضائيه او الصحف او الوكالات
بنقل حقيقي حتى نعرف من الخاسر ومن الكاتب
وايضا كما ذكرت قبل قليل صعوبه الاتصال
سيد محمود تصعب نقل المعلومه ونقل الوقائع
والحقائق
مقطوع تمام
اشير الى هذا العاجل الذي يريدنا من
الخارجيه الليبيه سيد محمود يقول بانهم
يقدرون دور السعوديه في عمليه اجلاء
المواطنين ورعايه ليبيا من السودان الى
مدينه جده سعيد بتواجدك معنا سيد محمود
ابقى معنا كرما
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
السودان
للسودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
دخل نحو عشره الاف اللاجئ الى الاراضي
الواقعه في جنوب السودان خلال الايام
الماضيه هاربين من القتال فيما عبر الحدود
نحو 6500 لاجئ سوداني يوم السبت الماضي في
وقت ما تزال به اعداد اللاجئين تتزايد الى
الاراضي الجنوب الجنوبيه من السودان خاصه
العاصمه جوبا
نعود الى ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني محمود لعوته سيد محمود
يعني وضع انساني صعب جدا كما ذكرت قبل
قليل في السودان ونحن سمعنا في الخبر قبل
قليل ان هناك نحو عشره الاف لاجئ وسته
الاف وخمسمائه ينزحون ويلجاون الى مناطق
اخرى كيف ترى مستقبل الوضع الانساني في
السودان في ظل كل هذه التطورات والمعارك
ويعني موضع كارثه في ظل تعطل المستشفيات
في ظل اغلاق المطارات في ظل وقوف يعني
يعني
الحركه يعني
مشلوله تماما في كل التحركات قله الوقود
قله المواد الغذائيه انقطاع الكهرباء
والمياه هذا كله يعني مثل اجزاء مهمه في
الحياه الانسان اليوميه اذا فقد الانسان
هذه الاشياء نعتقد الحياه حتكون بالنسبه
له صعبه فبالتالي يعني احنا شعرنا انه
الخرطوم فيها ممكن اكثر من خمسه او سته
ملايين انا اعتقد هذول كلهم ينزحون معظمهم
واهالي في الاقاليم يروحوا الى المدن
القريبه المدني النيل الابيض شندي المناطق
القريبه سوف ينزحون اليها ويمكسون هناك
هذا هذا اللي يستطيع ان يخرج يعني الان في
ناس ما عندهم
ما عندهم فلوس حتى يعني
يدفعوها
لاصحاب الناقلات والبصات والذين يعني الان
رفعوا الاسعار التساكر بشكل جنوني يمكن
وصلت ل 250 300% من السعر الاساسي يعني لا
تعاون حتى من اصحاب حتى لديهم فلوس الان
الخدمات البنكيه غير متوفره يعني
التطبيقات حتى التطبيقات البنكيه عطلت في
الجوالات
والوسائل الاخرى التي تستطيع منهم يستطيع
الوصول الى مناطق شمال السودان والحدود مع
مصر يعني مصر قدمت تسهيلات كبيره للاجئين
السودانيين انا بلاحظ انه في الان مجموعه
من الناس صاروا مثلي اجروا بس مثل يحتوي
على 50 او 100 شخص ويغادروا الى مصر
واعتقد لقوا استقبال يعني حار من الاخوه
المصريين على الحدود وانا اعتقد مصر هيكون
عليها لعب الاكبر في في استقبال اللاجئين
السودانيين خلال فتره الماضيه بحكم
العلاقه الجغرافيه بين السودانيين حتى
هنالك يعني مصاهره بين بعض الاسر
السودانيه والمصريه وانا اعتقد حيث يتجه
لمصر ولكن عموما يا اختي نحن لما نتكلم عن
مساله اللاجئين انا اعتقد ان هذه المنطقه
حتكون اكبر بؤره
للاجئين في العالم ليه لانه السودان محيط
باكثر من خمسه دول كلها كانت فيها صراعات
اهليه او حروب داخليه عندك افريقيا الوسطى
اثيوبيا اريتريا ليبيا
كل هذه الشات كل هذه الدول حتى هذه يعني
سكان هذه الدول الان هم لما كانت هذه
موجوده هذه الصراعات
الان حتكون في هجره معاكسه السودانيين سوف
يهاجم كما ذكرتيه في التقرير وانا اعتقد
حيكون للمنظمات الدوليه بدايه عيب كبيره
جدا في مشكله اللاجئين
المنظمات الدوليه والتدخلات الدوليه للوضع
الانساني في السودان يعني ذكرت قبل قليل
بان اجلاء المواطنين الاجانب كان في تدخل
عسكري يعني كان جنود من دولهم تاثير
لاجلائهم هل يمكن ان نرى ذات التصرف فيما
يخص المساعدات الانسانيه هل يمكن للدول ان
تستخدم هذه
الاليه العسك لايصال المساعدات ربما والله
يعني اذا كان في اطار لذلك اعتقد هذا هو
المطلوب يعني انا اعتقد المفروض الان انا
اتوقع بكره في جلسه لمجلس الان وحتكون في
قرارات انا اتمنى القرارات لا تكون مثلا
عقوبات على
الطيبين الطرفان انا اعتقد تكون في عقوق
عقوبات بقوه بتدخل يختلف عن التدخل الذي
تم في دول اخرى انا اعتقد انه الفروض
الامم المتحده تكون يعني مضطهده تماما من
مساله الدخول في السودان بالتدخل يعني
تقارنه
التدخل انه وجود
قوات اقليميه محايده من دول قريبه للسودان
لحفظ السلام لحفظ السلام وتكون من جنسيات
متعدده
وبكميات كبيره تستطيع ان تغطي كل المناطق
اللي بتحتاج يعني تغطيتها
ويكون لديها خطه محكمه وتركز على الجانب
الانساني في ظل وتتولى امور هذه حمايه هذه
المنظمات حتى يعني تسير القوافل الاغاثيه
المطلوبه للوصول للمحتاجين لهذه الاغاثه
يعني
راقدهم قبل قليل من برلين ذكرت بان
المانيا قالت بان اجلاء مواطنيها لم يكن
عب المطار الخرطوم ولكن عبر مطار اخر في
الخرطوم
مطار عسكريا مطار عسكرية
رفض ان يذكر الله لكن هو مطار عسكري يعني
هل يمكن استخدام هذا المطار العسكري
للمساعدات الانسانيه ممكن اذا تراضى
الطرفان ممكن يستخدم مطار الخرطوم او
مطارات اخرى الان في مطارات اخرى يعني مثل
مثل ما نقلوا
اللي هو موظفي البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والرعايه البلدان ممكن ان ينقلوا المنظمات
الدوليه من بورسودان الى الخرطوم بالطريقه
البري ايش المشكله نفس يعني نفس العمليه
يعني
تحت حمايه عسكريه شكرا جزيلا لك لحضورك
معنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي محمود
لعوته
[موسيقى]
من انقره ينضم الينا ابراهيم ناصر كاتب
وباحث سوداني اهلا بك معنا سيد ابراهيم
اذا وضع انسان صعب كما كنت اتحدث قبل قليل
مع ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو هل من خيارات
مطروحه على الطاوله
لحلحله هذه الازمه الانسانيه في السودان
طيب بدايه اهلا وسهلا بكم ومشاهديكم
الكرام نعم بكل تاكيدا تداعيات هذه الحرب
ستكون هي الكلف الانسانيه التي تقع على
المواطن السوداني كانت هناك مشاكل
اقتصاديه تعاني منها الدوله السودانيه
خلال الفتره الفائده بالتاكيد هذه الاوضاع
ستفاقم الوضع الانساني لكن الحلول تتمثل
في انه لابد من ان توجد مسارات انسانيه
يتم ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للمواطنين
وايضا لابد من يكون هناك المجتمع الدولي
ان يتحرك بصوره جاده للضغط على الاطراف
المتقاتله وايصال هذه المساعدات بصوره
سلسه دون التقيد باي شروط لكن اعتقد ان
الجاري والانساني فاقبه او الزم الجانب
الانساني تحركات هو قوات الميليشيات الدعم
السريعه التي تخندقت في منازل
المدنيين هذا ادى الى زياده
القتلى بين في صفوف المدنيين هذا كله طبعا
لابد من ان تتدارك القوى العسكريه او
الجيش السوداني يتعامل مع هذه الكارثه
بصوره جاده ان تكون هناك استهداف بصوره
عشوائيه للاماكن التي تتنظر فيها
المليشيات المتمرده لذلك اعتقد ان الجانب
الانساني هو الجانب الاخطر ولابد من قياده
ابراهيم اعذرني على المقاطعه
سنضطر الى ان نذهب الى جده الى مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي لينقل لنا وصول
طائرات الاجلاء تفضل سلطان
اطراف هنالك في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
سوف يقوم باستقبالنا السفير الكوري في
السعوديه هو عدد من قيادات القاعده هنا في
قاره الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده
لاستقبالهم نتحدث انه تم تسهيل كافه
الاجراءات لوصولهم نتحدث انه سوف يتم
الكشف عليهم والتاكد من صحتهم فورا وصولهم
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هنا في
مدينه جده هذه الطائره التي امامكم الان
سوف تقوم باقلالهم خلال ساعه القادمه بعد
وصول الطائره من مطار بورسودان بعد ان تم
اجلاؤهم من الخرطوم برا الى بورتسودان ومن
ثم سوف يصلون الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه
عبر الجو خلال الساعات القادمه تحمل على
متنها 29 شخص من الجنسيه الكوريه هم
جميعهم دبلوماسيين بمقدمتهم السفير الكوري
في السودان سوف يقوم باستقبالنا الكوري في
السعوديه وعدد من القيادات الامنيه هنا
سوف يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر في لحظه
وصوله من المديريه العامه للجوازات وكذلك
الجمارك لتسهيل عليهم
ويستطيعون فور او خلال ساعه واحده فقط بعد
وصوله الى القاعده السفر عبر هذه الطائره
العسكريه الضخمه وصولا الى سيول في كوريا
الجنوبيه نتحدث ان هذه الرحله هي اول رحله
اخلاء جوي تصل الى السعوديه عبر مطار
بورسودان تحط ريحانه خلال الساعات القادمه
الى مطار قاعده القاعده الجويه اوقات
الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده سبقها خلال
يومين الماضي عمليات اجلاء بحريه عبر
اربعه سفن وصل عددهم الى 157 شخص من ضمنهم
91 مواطن سعودي و66 مواطن اجنبي وخليجي
وعربي وكذلك من دول اوروبيه نتحدث على
بلغاريا وكندا ولكن نؤكد انه سوف تكون
الطائره الكوريه عمليه الاجلاء الاولى
الجويه سوف تصل الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه خلال الساعتين القادمه ومن ثم سوف
يتم نقلهم عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه
الكوريه بعد تنسيق امني كبير بين الحكومه
السعوديه والحكومه الكوريه لتسهيل
اجراءاتهم وفتح المجال لهم وانهاء كافه
الاجراءات المتعلقه بهم شكرا لك سلطان
سنتابع معك وصول الطائره بكل تاكيد
اعود الى ضيفي من انقره ابراهيم ناصر
الكاتب والباحث السوداني اهلا بك مجددا
السيد ابراهيم ونعتذر عن المقاطعه مره
اخرى كنا نتحدث عن الوضع الانساني الحرج
في السودان ولكن اود ان اتحدث معك الان عن
اتجاه الصراع الى اين يذهب
طيب نعم هذا الصراع طبعا هو الصراع كسر
عظام يعني لا اعتقد ان ان هذه الاطراف قد
تصل الى مرحله من من التفاوض باعتبار ان
كلا الاطراف جيشت حواضنها سياسيه وحواضنها
العسكريه حتى يتم قضاء طرف على طرف اخر
عمليه الاجلاء التي تمت تؤشر انه هذا
الوضع سيصل الى مرحله من الصدامه الى
مرحله من الصدام اللام لا ينتهي الا
بنهايه الطرف من الاطراف لكن اعتقد تخوفات
المجتمع الدولي والمجتمع الاقليمي ربما
تؤدي الى الى جلوس الاطراف الى طاوله
المفاوضات وانا استبعد هذا الامر لانه
قوات دعم سريع تحاول ان تطيل امد هذه
الحرب بحيث يكون هناك تدخلات وان تفرض
شروطها على الجيش السوداني الذي يعتبر ان
هذه الميليشيا تغولت على مؤسسات الصلبه
خلال الفتره الماضيه حاولت ان طفرت شروطها
وحاول ان تشتري بعض الاطراف لصالح ان
تتقوى هذه الميليشيا لكن بالتاكيد الجيش
السوداني بان هذه المليسه هي مهدد للامن
هي كانت تمثل جسم شاذ في التشكيله
العسكريه في السودان لذلك اعتقد ان الجيش
السوداني عازم الى ازاحه هذه المليشه من
المشهد حتى يكون هناك الجيش موحد تندمج
فيه كل الميليشيات وكل المكونات المسلحه
التي كانت تقاتل الدوله السودانيه لذلك
اعتقد انه سيناريو المفاوضات ربما يكون
ضعيف ما لم تنكسر شوكه هذه المليشيا وان
تتراجع ويتراجع نفوذها العسكري او
الميداني وان تحارب من كل الاتجاهات لذلك
اعتقد ان الجيش هو الذي سيحسم هذه هذه
التفلتات او هذه الميليشيا بصوره باعتبار
انها وصلت الى مرحله من الضعف حتى لم يكن
هناك اتصال بين القواعد والقياده المركزيه
فقدت الاتصال وذكرت المعلومات التي
اصدرتها والبيانات التي اصدرتها القياده
العسكريه الجيش السوداني ذكرت له ان هذه
المليشيا فقدت السيطره ولا تستطيع ان تشون
هجمات موسعه الا سوى انت تكون تنتصر على
على المدينه وان تكون لها تحركات بين صفوف
المدنيين حتى تزيد من الخسائر
لصالح هذا الطرف او ذاك هل سيقبل الشعب
السوداني بهذه النتائج يعني هم يعني يبدو
انهم لا يريدون اي كيان سياسي اي كيان
عسكري في المشهد السياسي فما ان حسبت
المعركه لاي الطرفين هل سيقبل الشعب بهذه
النتيجه
طبعا ثوره ديسمبر كانت من ضمن اطالبها ان
يحقق نظام ديمقراطي مدني دون ان يكون هناك
تغول على او عسكره المشهد هذه هذه من ضمن
المسلمات التي خرج من اجلها الشباب
السوداني اعتقد ان حميه بتقديرات خاطئه
حاول ان يستغل هذه الرغبات لكي يقول بانه
يمثل التحول الديمقراطي وهذا ما تروج له
ابواقه الاعلاميه في مختلف الاطراف لكن في
واقع الامر ان عسكره المشهد سيوعد التحول
الديمقراطي والمدني الى ما لا نهايه ليس
لم يكن هناك اي تحول ديمقراطي في ظل غلبه
اي طرف على الطرف الاخر لذلك مواطن
السوداني يعي الخسائر ستكون كبيره ولكن
على اقل تقدير ان الجيش السوداني في حال
تسلم المشهد او ضبط هذه هذه المليشيا
وحاول ان يسيطر القوه او يكون له بيده
القوه الصلبه او القوه العسكريه بيده من
المؤكد سيكون هناك مفاوضات على اساس ان
يزيح المشهد
الجيش السوداني من مشهد السياسي وهذا ما
ود ما وعد به البرهان
والجيش السوداني واعد بانه سيزيح من
العمليه السياسيه بصوره كامله ويترك
المدنيين الى ان يحققوا تحول ديمقراطي
وهذا ما حصل في تاريخ السودان يعني عندما
كان اسوار الذهب قائده للجيش السوداني
احدث تحول وسلم سلطه المدنيين وهذا معهود
من الجيش السوداني وهذا ما هو المتوقع لكن
في ظل تواجد هذه المليشه على المشهد
السوداني من الصعب جدا ان يكون هناك تحول
مدني ديمقراطي وبدايه التحول الديمقراطي
تبدا بازاحه هذه الميليشيا التي تغولت على
المؤسسات الصلبه والمؤسسات الاقتصاديه
وشوه علاقه السودان الخارجيه وازمت علاقات
السودان الامنيه مع مختلف الدول لذلك
اعتقد ان الاوضاع ستكون مهزومه بكل تاكيد
ما لم تزاح هذه المليشه من المشهد واضح
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من انقره ابراهيم ناصر
الكاتب والباحث السوداني
[موسيقى]
ربنا يجعلكم
فرصه
[موسيقى]
الاخباريه انتهت ولكن تغطيتنا للاحداث في
السودان مستمره الزميله ميسون عزام تلقاكم
على راس الساعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات